you doing?
You are wasting
edge of death time.
Make a move.
What do you what
me to do?
My talent can't be
to like, wash his body.
You mean like, wash his
body after sex, right?
I want to make sure you're
optimizing your fantasies.
All right, it's
the first thing I thought of.
I know
what we will do.
I know what we
will do.
You say, "Let's
play Truth or Dare."
You pick me, I say, "Dare"
and then--
Got it, got it,
got it, got it.
Say no more.
Okay, cool.
10, yes!
(Matt)
Whoo!
Champion!
(Jeremy coughing)
Don't feel bad.
I'm on speed.
Yeah.
Okay, you guys.
Truth or Dare.
No, come on.
We have to finish
the talent show.
No, we don't.
Um, hmm... Who should I--
who wants to-- Abbi.
Truth or dare?
You know what,
I'm gonna go with dare.
Okay.
I dare you to
suck Jeremy's (bleep).
(thunder rubmling)
Um, that's a wrap
on Truth or Dare.